COMI
WAS A THING OF BEAUTY.
WATCH
>> Hubie: GOT PLENTY OF BOSTON ,
WILL MIKEROTATION, AND A
GREAT BLOCK.
THIS IS WHERE GIANNIS IS
BUT THAT IS A JUST DON'T HAVE M
OTHER BODIES TO THROW AT TRIED
MATCHUP.
>> Lisa: AND THEY'VE ALL BEEN
INVOLVED HERE TONIGHT TO. CHANC.
FELLA. TO PLAY BOTH ENDS OF
THE FLOOR TO GET MORE MINUTES,
ESPECIALLY WITH ALL OF HIS
GO.
DEFLECTED, PASS TO CONNAUGHTON,
THEY'RE
GIANNIS ON THE PUSH. A QUICK
CROSSOVER.
THE LONGG
TWO.
>> Lisa: OH, 805. AND-ONE.
[ LAUGHTER ] MATCH STICK.
HIS SENDS IT BACK, AND THOUGHT
BRISSETT.
>> Lisa: GIANNIS.
HAND OR
BOTH; IF NEED BE.
ACTIVE IN THE ZONE.
HE GAVE CREDIT T ABOUT BRANDON
ABILITY TOHE MISSES ON THE SHOV
ANTICIPATED A FOUL FRORO
BASKET.
SO, SO DIFFICULT TO DEFEND IN A
SPRAIN.
MISSING THE FIFTH CONSECUTIVE
GAME TONIGHT.DN'T SEE SWITCH AG
SAVED THERE BY ALLEGIANNIS'
LANE TO THE RIM, THE FINALS MVP
>> Ian: ANDPASS.
DON'T GET ME WRONG.
BUT I LIKE TO SEE THAT SWITCH I
JOB STEPPING UP.
ALLENGES GOBERT.
TAKE THE
ROOKIE
DEFENSIVE REBOUNDING AT THE
END
DON'T SLEEP ON HIM.
>> Vince: ABSOLUTELY.
PLAYING WITHOUT JOEL
SHOWING WHY.
SOME THINGS JUSTD THAT'S GOOD
INEXPLPL
THREE AS WELL.
>> Mark: MIDDLETON ON THE WING.
DAVIS SWITCHES JRUE
FEET. STEP.
>> Lisa: CELTICS WITH 10-1